this is the silence a good thing or a
bad thing
this silence good or bad I don't know
what's up guys I'm Joshua I'm Kerry
Harry here thinks that she can go into
anybody's kitchen using only the
ingredients that they have and make them
one of the best meals they've ever had
uh yeah
I can oh my goodness baby you don't get
wrinkles on your face with so much doubt
I'm super confident I don't think you
can do it well they have a can of tuna
some baking soda and some butter how do
you like your filet I say we recreate a
little wager here the bet is this I bet
that you can't go into someone's kitchen
and make them one of the best meals I've
ever had I'm going to up your wager to
win the bet who's ever kitchen we go to
that person has to say this is the best
meal I've ever had I get to pick the
person whose house we're going to
awesome awesome we're on our way to our
destination
you don't know where we're going I don't
know where we're going I'm just excited
to be traveled like the person I chose
we're going to a friend who is a vegan
and Kerry's not vegan she doesn't cook
vegan food every day Charlotte yeah I'm
Charlotte I am a vegan I'm kind of like
a vegan terian in case there are any
vegan police watching this when I first
became vegan I was super excited and I
would cook all the time as time has
progressed I've gotten busier after a
long day of work I don't really feel
like coming home and cooking and I'll be
honest I get kind of lazy and I'll just
go on to GrubHub I feel guilty about it
because I have food in my fridge like
good food in my fridge but I just don't
feel like cooking and I don't have that
energy to cook it go for the bed if I
win you have to stand on the side of
some street corner somewhere wearing a
diaper holding a sign that says
eat your veggies have you been thinking
about this for because that is so
specific yeah if I win you have to go
vegan for a whole week
no meat no turkey no salmon none of that
and almost rather no eggs
Oh Oh your bestest friend all the lands
with her friend who likes to eat meat
all the time we're here to cook your
fridge well I have a recipe spreadsheet
I print recipes out and I put them on my
microwave so that I'll see them
I'll buy the ingredients for the recipes
but I don't ever cook the stuff let's
get into my baking coverage okay what is
this that is some old or chocolate mix
from my mother this is my pride and joy
all my seasonings welcome to my fridge
you want to talk about your meat that's
cool that they make meat that tastes
like meat that's not really me is this
everything she has to work with yes okay
you ready to do this thing uh I think
I'm ready I just need one more thing I
started I need you to get out kitchen
what can I get my wife first things
first before we get started I have to
turn the AC on it's hot in here so is
our guy
yeah yeah yep Charlotte has a lot of
canned goods she has some vegetables and
fruits like things and I'm gonna do
savory quinoa and it's crazy it's gonna
be sweet and savory so I'm gonna add
some strawberries I'm gonna do some
roasted nuts and basil roasted carrots
and ginger oh I think I'm also gonna add
because I'm crazy some of this cafe 45
minutes and we're gonna make this happen
are you a meat-eater I'll do about 3/4
of a cup of the quinoa and we'll just
set it aside wait to the water boil you
wonder where fashion is see with me - I
can't even think got a twin I know -
copy much we ate the sinks I don't know
you found them so why you like we make
this Prince Geco we fade away I can say
this I could give it to tail and take it
in okay I just thought of something I
want to add a little sweetness to the
quinoa so I'm gonna add a little coconut
milk the quinoa is super absorbent so
really whatever I put in it's gonna take
on those flavors so now that I have most
the ingredients chopped up for the
quinoa I'm going to roast my carrots I'm
gonna roast my nuts it's gonna be
delicious for vegans beans are a great
way to get protein and I'm going to take
these garbanzo beans and I'm actually
gonna roast them up let's try some
Chipotle roasted garlic let's do some
ground cumin
so I've added the carrots and a little
bit of the kale and we're gonna shove it
in the oven and let it bake for a little
bit now we're gonna get ready to make
the tempeh I'm going to do a soy maple
and garlic sauce I think as Charlotte
doesn't have soy she has a Liquid Amino
so it's a soy sauce alternative which is
nice for anyone who is gluten-free
I'm just gonna add the strawberries and
the basil and the onions to the tempeh
just to start baking it with the rest of
the flavor she's doing in there I don't
know okay
I'm a little bit worried hey how you
doing today I didn't sound good
I guess she sounds like she's lacking
confidence right now the quinoa I feel
like tastes really bland so I need to
figure out how to season that up and I
need to figure out something I've had
her food before and it's very good
so I'm I'm going out on faith you have
to say it's one of the best things
you've ever had that's a lot I really
don't want to be in a diaper at all now
you're making me hungry
limited to a funky dessert I'm actually
gonna use that old or Chadha that she
had and mix it into a pumpkin pie cup
Carrie told me to you see cooking in the
kitchen and it's hot what is that smell
it's burning
I need to go take my turn in
I'm not gonna lie to do a lot more
difficult than I thought it was going to
be I'm not used to using vegan
ingredients so my pie crust is really
crumbly this looks like something out of
a restaurant if we're going off of looks
alone she one shade up I agree
oh geez while she's taking her time I at
least have to try this here we go your
wife's made of this did you get some
tempeh in there too look the tempeh is
one of the best tempers I've ever had
for sure the quinoa not my favorite on a
scale of one to ten of all the vegan
meals I've ever had six okay hold on oh
there's more can I bring out the dessert
all right so here's ago this was not one
of the rules she so what I'm wondering
is if I bring out the dessert and the
dessert is amazing I will allow this
dessert to be a part of the rule but
it's got to be the best like we're not
playing around you say so I made a
gluten-free coconut flour or Tata
pumpkin peanut butter pie why with a
rose chocolate sauce rose chocolate yeah
you had some rose cocoa powder and so I
made a chocolate ganache to put on top
of the peanut butter pumpkin God she
just like pulled the rug out from under
you with this I'm really nervous
I also topped it off with a little bit
of Himalayan pencil
[Music]
this is the silence a good thing or a
bad thing
the silence good or bad I don't know can
we just say officially so that we know
what who the winner of this bet is it's
one of the best vegan meals you've ever
had it is an finish it I am floored by
this I haven't had a lot of vegan
desserts this is one of the best
desserts period that I've had yeah it's
like I'm kind of like Fiesta in my mouth
I lost and I will be vegan for a week
and I survive and I will survive I
thought I ruined the dessert
sugar inside of the pumpkin mix it
wasn't until I had that like last-minute
idea of we're gonna have to pull
something out of a hat I hate losing a
bet but to lose a bet like this and get
to eat something like that is incredible
I am so not excited we need to do this
again because I need to win now I have
to figure out what I'm gonna go eat for
the next seven days